-Guys, it's time to take a look
at the stories making headlines
today and weigh the good
with the bad.
It's time for "Pros and Cons."
Here we go.
♪ -Pros and cons
and pros and cons and pros ♪
-Tonight we'll be taking a look
at the pros and cons of
Thanksgiving travel.
That's right -- tomorrow is
Thanksgiving, and this year,
the number of people traveling
to see their families is
expected to get back to
nearly pre-pandemic levels.
So let's take a look at the pros
and cons of Thanksgiving travel.
Here we go right here.
Pro -- you'll finally get to see
your family.
Con -- you'll finally get to see
It's a real double-edged sword.
-Blessing and a curse.
-Pro -- 4.2 million Americans
will travel by airplane.
Con -- And they all believe
they deserve the armrest.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pro -- Listening to the radio
on a family road trip.
Con -- Hearing dad try to hit
that high note in "Easy on Me."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Vocalizes ]
Pro -- Getting vaccinated
so that you can eat
Thanksgiving dinner
with your family.
Con -- Having to sit at
the Johnson & Johnson table.
Oh, that's --
[ Laughter ]
Come on!
-In the basement.
-Pro -- there's less
vehicle traffic
if you leave late Wednesday.
Con -- Assuming Waze doesn't
give the other 20,000 people
the same "shortcut."
[ Laughter and applause ]
You're special.
-No way, everybody's going
this weird road.
-Yeah, you're special.
We didn't tell anyone else.
Pro -- Everyone on the plane
wears a mask
to prevent the spread of COVID.
Con -- until they bust out
those Biscoff cookies,
then all bets are off.
[ Laughter ]
"Ooh, are those Biscoff?"
Nom, nom, nom.
[ Laughter ]
Pro -- American
and Alaska Airlines
require their employees
to be vaccinated.
Con -- Southwest is handing out
Flintstone vitamins
and hoping for the best.
[ Laughter ]
Pro -- If you're nervous to fly,
some airports have
emotional support animals.
Con -- They're all provided by
Joe Exotic.
[ Laughter ]
There you go, everybody.
Those are the "Pros and Cons."